can I work for free for you number one
is that if you're going to try and do
this approach if you're like hey Elon
can I get your coffee for you like Elon
doesn't need you to get his coffee this
issue I that I see amongst poor people
that think that their time is worth
something and it's not there's no
shortage of low-skilled Labor number two
is you want to make them an offer that's
so good that they feel stupid saying no
let's not pretend here like my life is
not better off because you're in it now
your life is going to be significantly
better because I'm in it and I get this
in my DMs all the time hey I'd like to
do this in exchange for working you know
along inside you no the whole principle
of giving first isn't an offer to give
first it is giving first period without
expectation of something back